passion is not an input passion is an
output
uh passion um you know we're all
passionate we're just not all passionate
for the same things
and we will feel what we call passion
when we are involved in something
that is deeply personal to us that is
helping us advance
some higher purpose or cause then when
we go to work what we
what we experience is passion but if you
make us do something that we feel no
personal connection to that is not as
helping advance any kind of
bigger ideal than what we feel is stress
now passionate people work many hours
they don't come home they miss their
families
they take business trips they they don't
sleep
and yet it feels worth it people who are
stressed go on
business trips they miss their families
they work long hours they don't sleep
but it doesn't feel worth it
passion is an output not an input like
stress is an output not an
input so you don't you can't do what
you're passionate about
you find something you believe in and
what you will experience is passion
so then it begs the question how do i
find what i believe in right
there's a i think society especially our
society
and especially for a younger generation
puts overwhelming pressure on us
to have a vision what's your vision or
find your blessing all of these they're
all the same thing right
and the problem is we're not all
visionaries it's unfair
it's an unfair standard that's like
telling everybody
to be creative but we're not all
creative or everybody be good at math
but we're not all good at math
we're not all visionaries only a small
percentage of our population are
actually visionary
you don't have to have a vision you have
to find a vision
right if you hear martin luther king
say i have a dream that one day little
black children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
you go
that's what i want you choose to follow
dr king
when you hear the words of visionaries
and if they appeal to you on some
visceral level they give you goosebumps
they make you excited
they make you want to sacrifice be a
part of it stand in line
to hear them pay money whatever it is
follow that make that your vision take
it and say that's my vision too
you can adopt someone else's vision and
make it your own that's what we call
a following is we have taken the
visionary's vision
and we have chosen to follow that vision
ourselves we are followers
that's a good thing there's no
difference between the visionary and the
follower
we both see ourselves in service to
something bigger than ourselves
whether you are the originator of that
idea or not is irrelevant
what it does is fuel passion what it
does is fuel conviction
so we don't have to have a vision but we
do have to
find one and so read books watch ted
talks
read articles be in life
watch videos you know go out seek find
listen
listen to leaders corporate political
whoever
and when something resonates with you
even if you don't know why
that then you can adopt and you can take
it upon yourself to use your own
talents your own gifts to help advance
whatever that cause is
right so i have a cause i have a crystal
clear vision of the world i want to live
in i
imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
at work
and return home fulfilled at the end of
the day the gift that i have committed
to help advance that cause
is the ability to put some of these
ideas into words that other people can
relate to
you know when you do a jigsaw puzzle the
first thing you do is lean the box
against the wall
right we all have a piece of the puzzle
to help build this vision
my piece of the puzzle is i'm the guy
that points at the box
but i'm not the guy who builds the
business
because there are other people who are
better at that the entrepreneurs and the
business leaders
i want them to embrace the same picture
on the box
the people who work for companies who
say i want to work for a company that
does that
that's their piece the one who's a
gifted natural leader
who cares we all have at least one
friend
who for whatever reason love us and care
us even when we're horrible people
that that for some reason they still
believe in us and they see the good in
us
that's their piece of the puzzle and so
we have to commit our gifts the reason
they call them gifts is because they're
forgiving
that's what gifts are they're forgiving
away if you have a gift it's not
something you take it's something you
give
so i think we have to find a vision and
commit our gifts to help advance that
vision
and the great leaders the ones that can
put that vision into words
so clear that we can then recite that
vision as if it were our own
[Music]